hi everyone welcome to our digital hub i
likey i hope you do too
and i'm very excited to be with our
guest today it's none other than one of
my icons z-way
hi listen i'm a crazy rebel i push the
envelope i'm never not going to
but thank you but i don't think i have
your
and i just i don't i disagree
i fundamentally disagree i think you are
one of the most brave women in
entertainment i
am just when i watch you with friendly
bewets when i watch you with allison
roman and there are some gotcha moments
there are some you set people up
you know a little bit to fail sometimes
i think that's inherently the concept
but
it's also you reveal things
these truths
that are just mind-blowing
thank you i like to think of it as no i
don't have the right answers there
actually is no right answer to how many
black turns do you have and that's the
fun how brave is it to come on someone's
show and just be open
that's special i did love that you
called the friend leave without for
being like do you know what show you are
watching
so that's cool oh see i love your take
on it because how many talk shows have
you done in your life where it's like
you you get sheltered from one place to
the other you talk about like you
promote your whatever and it's so hollow
and fake and there's nothing really
since whereas that interview is so
special she's been interviewed for
decades and she's never done anything
like that before you will reveal things
you'll have gotchas you clearly do your
research i love
that the amount of research you do and i
think that is
coming from that really educated place
you can fly
like i like to do my homework a lot of
people love to i feel like i show up
naked for a test that i haven't studied
for when i haven't gone into a
conversation really educated like it's a
sick awful feeling i will not
put myself through oh you got it you got
it i got it you got to do the book you
got to listen to the podcast you got to
know listen to the other ones made you
that kind of person that's that thorough
uh um curiosity honestly and also when
you're talking to someone they they
mention things from their past and it's
if you're not really listening you're
actively listening it just flies over
your head so i like to know
everything
exactly it makes for a better interview
and something that isn't shallow and bad
okay i mean did you ever know that you
would find yourself here in this field
with the connective tissue because you
is it true you used to get in trouble
when you were a kid for being so curious
and asking pointed questions yes the
very thing that's led to your success
today exactly well i i was just i would
ask too many questions i even had an
improv teacher that was like you're not
supposed to start a scene by asking
questions supposed to initiate whatever
and look at me now so i think the lesson
is um don't listen to adults ask a lot
of questions
i mean it really impresses me because if
you
were someone i'm just meeting you for
the first time you know i've studied you
i know your persona um i've also watched
you just you know in your social media
and fashion love and who you are
personally outside of your show and i
feel well versed in that but i was like
so curious as to
what your vibe was gonna be like like
you could have presented a lot of
different things what is my vibe you're
so pleasant and thank you like you don't
is that a surprise well
if you would come in here with like a
real kind of confidence and attitude i
wouldn't have been surprised
um the fact that you're so warm and soft
like is like
you're like
me too shut up
wait february 22nd february 27th
oh my god thank god you're not a lead
here that's always so awkward
and we're early pisces yes pisces us and
rihanna
oh yeah oh mary elizabeth taylor yes
that's right i
i do think
supposedly in the astrology world the
beginning middle and end of a cycle
means something yeah
there's no path you can't get out of it
it's to tell the truth
[Music]
have you ever flipped off a stranger no
no i don't think i've ever used a middle
finger at anyone in ire oh my honestly
okay have you ever sworn to secrecy but
then accidentally spilled the beans
no secrets are safe with me secrets are
sacred
i agree i agree have you ever been fired
yeah absolutely and i was terrible at
those jobs i was really bad at some jobs
too have you ever loved a movie but
secretly like didn't get it you know it
was like the love of like
forced
you know
majority yes but then i just call it
camp oh it's camp
i don't understand it because it's camp
it's you know it's retro it's him
i i definitely like i had never seen wet
hot american summer i was so irritated
with everyone loving it so much and then
i saw it and i was like oh it's kind of
awesome
yeah it's really good actors like you
don't you people they don't get enough
credit for how the timing of it well and
comedy isn't awarded they should have an
oscars literally for comedy okay speak
about it i don't think about it make me
bleed and
and and everything has to be so painful
to win an award
have you ever lied to get a job yes yeah
yes i can horseback ride yes i know how
to play the piano yes i can speak french
yeah by the way that is so 80s resume
too like all actors had to show like
their skill sets and they were all
motorcycles
moonwalking whatever the special skill
is honey i have it do you have any
tattoos no do you have any tattoos yeah
a lot yeah um and i love all of them i
wish i had a tattoo if you were to get
one what would you get i don't even know
that's why i don't have a tattoo maybe a
circle maybe a heart and why a circle
it's just infinity the beginning it's
the beginning pisces culture it's the
beginning in the end of the zodiac it's
full i love the heart shape too like it
is one line if you can draw it that way
most people go happy i draw my hearts
like this
okay
a circle would be that
simple really clean it's cute it's clean
it's like that's i think that's the
first shape i ever learned about maybe
we'll get one in vegas
this is like a dream this is really fun
and hopefully the beginning of lots of
collaborations
[Music]
you